dix transporteurs sont très tôt devant
la sahara sous la surveillance des
policiers qui sont restés en faction
toute la nuit ils ne savent pas encore
s'ils pourront charger du carburant en
effet la veille ils ont dû rebrousser
chemin
nous attendons que la raffinerie somme
pour aller charger ya un espoir de
charger ou ce matin ben oui oui puisque
nous voyons que la barrière est en train
de s'ouvrir 6 heures les choses bougent
des camions entre enfin de la raffinerie
le signal est donné ils pourront
s'approvisionner
trente minutes après les premiers
camions ressortent les transporteurs
sont satisfaits ils ont fait le plein
36 26 on l'aurait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a plus on avait chargé
est bon mais on va livrer c'est quelque
chose de formidable
vous allez livrer ou est bien là je
monte robert la livrer à la station 69
là vous allez où je vais arriver à la
station de l'aéroport il n'y a pas de
temps à perdre
les cuves doivent être remplies au plus
vite pour éviter la rupture
depuis hier c'est l'accueil sur la piste
normalement on est à vomir tous les
jaunes de carburant la brutalité ou est
en temps normal je pense qu'on peut
gagner trois jours trois jours
en temps normal sans grève sa
précipitation dont sept autres stations
service la situation différente
il n'y a pas encore de carburant depuis
quand y'a pas l'essence et puis hier
après midi vers 17 heures 17 heures
là j'espère y être livrés oui oui ta
faute est aujourd'hui pour continuer à
travailler pas de blocage de la sarre a
aujourd'hui toutes les stations service
ont été approvisionnés donc il n'ya pas
de raison qu'il y ait de longues files
d'attentes pour faire de l'essence